[Music]
okay should be live
here let me
uh think that this got
bumped
right yeah this got
okay
hi got a lot of cool stuff to do today
ran some experiments
um good morning run
here some
intervals getting faster sub 6:30 pace
for the first
one uh We've also got
V3 yeah there was definitely a
performance regression with this one
holy
CL that is awful um that will take some
additional
experimentation yeah
so let me double check a couple things
to get started here we've got Noah
potentially trying to
fix some environments
[Music]
uh and that's about it okay so I think
things are in a decent spot at the
moment um I just there's another cool
Library I found out about
today so there's this other Library
somebody wrote uh C pure C++ RL which is
awesome M seem a little more limited but
there are some nice little control tasks
in here uh so hopefully we will get
bindings from for these for puffer CU
these are quite
nice and uh depending on how this works
potentially there can even be uh these
could potentially even go on web which
would be
awesome I had a chat with this guy this
is very good work uh I assume I have not
looked at the actual code
yet there does seem to be a decent chunk
of stuff with this though we'll
see uh we're going to do I think we're
going to do some performance testing
today more than anything because I got
this new box and I want to figure
out why it's not getting the performance
I should
expect yeah this is literally
soup it's like way too thick
made so first of all I want to see if I
can
find some bench marks as to where this
thing is supposed to
be so this is a $500
processor this is a $700 processor
says this is getting higher multicore
per but I wonder what Baseline they're
using
10% so the real applications thing is
because of the P core e core thing we
can handle that but we should be
expecting like a 10% perf bump
okay so we have to actually see if we
can get these workloads or these uh
performance numbers
yeah these numbers this is crap crap
don't just use your benchmark
Mark should be 10% faster right single
thread
rating should be about the same here
okay let's see if any of my boxes are
idle right
and think how I want to do this I don't
want to mess anything up on
this some point OS and
compiler yeah but the thing is I'm
getting way more than a couple percent
difference I'm pretty
sure like I'm trying to figure out why
I'm getting nowhere near the performance
like I bought a $5,500 machine that's
like at least 25% slower close to 50%
slower than a $4,000 machine and I'm not
happy about
it um so I'm trying to figure out what
the heck is going on
what um if that YouTube message if the
you're not a bot uh we have a Discord
it's it's discord.gg
simple
um I know I think something more
fundamental is screwy and I'm trying to
figure out what we're doing uh some good
perf tests today today on uh I9 14900 K
versus uh
AMD uh ren9
950x as well as figuring out why 490
appears to be faster than the other
so I'm trying to think what perf test
would be good to run
have yeah so here we have Our Risen
processor
do
and there
okay so we got to figure out the
variance here
unexpected so is the issue then
that maybe there was like a global
performance
yeah let's figure out if this if inbs
any different
awful note yourself do not heat after
mixing holy
okay so
now when we train
breakout we're getting um
at least a good
19 18
19,000 and we are spending 80% time in
the environment 7%
I'm surprised it's not faster we'd
gotten all the way up to 30k before I
thought uh hang on maybe the settings
are different
why okay now you can
see massively
higher profile steps per second and
let's see if it's consistent
yeah so very
consistently 4500
is there like a perf thing with WSL
being garbage
fine oh I forgot to do my uh my on
stream overlay as well I got to fix
bizarre okay
um next perf test I guess
okay that's actually like a two out of
10 for Taste
regressions run this a couple more times
make sure it's
interesting so it could just literally
be at tar it looks like
okay
15K standard
deviation okay 8,000
so and then we just have to do me and
Ino
let's actually do it on this one so I
have
right this is what
it
uh where did you get time
from it just time.
this was a disaster I'm going to drink
it but
holy it's horrible
okay snake 2.1 million steps per second
apparently
can you
turn screen chat yeah let me figure out
how to do
that um this is a new machine
on sources
browser got
that looks good
right that might be too small we'll
see you can let me know how that
is how did I used to do this I think I
put myself over here and then Chad over
here or
whatever yeah this is hold on this is
not
ideal width has got to be way less like
that readable or is that too
small that's probably really
be go like
this we'll see whether I decide to go
get better camera as well this is the
cheaper one I have my uh I'm in Florida
I don't have my the other scen setups in
California this is all new stuff I also
have to get a better cable for the mic
so I can angle
it
properly all right we got chat back
though at the very
least yeah I forgot you totally can't
see all the chats
otherwise my bad
we'll up the stream we'll up the stream
game pretty quick
here uh okay what are our results
oh wait did I do these
wrong no wait this is the this is the
AMD one
right yeah this is am I have backwards
holy that would have been
bad this is my
I don't know how it's possible for it to
be 3x faster though I mean this is like
50k I be so careful with this because I
keep have
to write them
down 9.3
mil 55k standard deviation AMD is 2.4
and then let me think what other things
I can try on
I'm worried about the OS on this causing
the uh the issues if it is the OS by the
way I'm ditching Windows forever
if this is actually the OS causing the
overhead I like ditching Windows
I don't need to run the test actually I
just need to run the single core portion
so 23
I actually don't even know how it's
possible for these chips this chip to be
this bad
I'm hoping it's like Windows but I don't
the thing is I literally have to wipe
this box to test that don't I I guess I
could dual boot it
be okay um
yeah I mean benchmarking more of these
is not going to change this result I
don't think um this is
insane I think I need to get some sort
of like
standard Benchmark to
see if my uh if my CPU is matching what
it should be on the factory because
that's like nuts
okay so there is these guys actually do
look like they
have suspense results this is
good let's try this
we want single core I think
first I mean I know that there're
heavier things you can
run but uh I want to just see if the CPU
is
performing like if it's performing
correctly uh if it's performing
according to what like other people are
reporting then it's not my specific chip
or setup it's just the chip being bad
bench hey YouTube
folks we are doing a bit of work at the
moment to figure out optimal RL Hardware
settings considering I got this new
machine and now the question is do we
move machines in the future to AMD or do
we keep Intel despite all the
issues
all so
is there anywhere where people just
report sis
these benchmarks are useless if no one
Aggregates them here we're going to run
this
again and we're going to run it
on the other
yeah this one doesn't need standard
deviation this one is
very this one's
consistent 650
default
right for
so that's crazy you can run the test but
it locks up the
PC
um okay so interestingly this actually
does scale up
to uh this does actually scale up to 32
threads so this one I think you have 32
total
I got to find this result from somewhere
to see if I can find a comparable
basically I need to find if somebody has
run
this I'm going to have to take a second
to use the restroom in a in a bit as
well this is not going well this
drink yeah I'm going to do that right
now I'll be back in just a couple
okay the um
1 th000 calorie mug recipe might need a
few changes it might just need a few
changes that's
fine I don't mind doing dumb [ __ ] many
many times in order to figure stuff
out
so 66 to 60 47 47 so according to this
this should be very very similar in
perf um and I'm just not seeing it
oh there are uh there's a distribution
it
see this one's actually even heavier to
the right
perf well I'm not seeing it in my RL
test let's do does geek bench have a
thing cross PL
file which of these is the uh the
runnable
x6d hopefully this doesn't take scam
down
okay that's actually a pretty nice uh
Suite that they've developed to just
have a bundle executable that they just
ship
more software needs to be that
way I still haven't finished
do not microwave the Thousand calorie
mug
welcome we're doing Hardware
benchmarking at the moment today we're
trying to figure out optimal uh hardware
specs for
RL what is it
The Benchmark or the
mug we're looking at AMD 950x versus I94
900k right
now rating for V3 mug absolutely God
awful do not
microwave the mug I I figured it might
be better if I um mix it and then M or
if I blend it and then microwave it I
figured that would work better it caused
the way to like expand and you're like
you basically have to chew it it's
disgusting
H mug
trials I mean a lot of the stuff is look
the like the foresight for like how to
structure stuff and reinforcement
learning how I'm like designing stuff to
push the fields forward yeah that took
me like 10 years of experience right but
like getting good enough to build useful
RL environments to run good experiments
like all the smaller stuff can be picked
up very very
quickly and uh you know we've got all
this stuff open source and lots of
people helping people pick stuff up it's
just about putting in the
time thanks for making puffer lib
working uh with it on one of my
Neuroscience projects heck yeah more
people using puffer
lib it's only going to get
better I'm working on it full
time please introduce what puffer lib
does in simple uh puffer lib makes
reinforcement learning a heck of a lot
easier to do it's a very simple Library
that's very very fast it introduces very
fast simulations as well for testing
stuff on uh and generally we're making
all the slow janky stuff with this field
go away that's the simplest version of
it it's really it's my effort to build
the library for reinforcement learning
that I wish existed as a PhD student and
that
didn't it is intended for both academic
research and for uh industry as well
it's all free and open source for people
and companies I do sell support packages
in fact some of what I'm doing now uh is
part of one of those
is
AMD single core
multicore single core m
multicore so what we do will what we'll
do now is we'll see whether this
remotely matches what it should
be for these
processors I'm just doing a bunch of
different Basel lines I don't know if
geekbench is any good I'm just I'm not
I'm just trying to see if I'm my results
match other people's results essentially
working on RL project with traffic
optimization and simulation is that
possible
absolutely uh yeah
absolutely so we
have let me show
you this is from NYU doing driving Sim
uh you can see staple baselines
implementation 25 to 50K puffer lip
implementation 200 to 500k so literally
10 times faster in puffer lib and a lot
simpler as well
um any sorts of Sims you can add to
puffer make very very fast and generally
pretty simple to do so interested to
help picking up ourl knowledge at the
moment couple of months I'll be good
enough uh what's your programming
background like literally if you've
taken a single systems course at all you
already know enough to contribute
productively the way that I generally
suggest people get into puffer is start
off come help build some environments
you'll get a sense of how environments
have to be built and structured for RL
which is really crucial and then we
slowly onboard people onto the science
side from there I have a quick start
guide as well I don't know if you've
seen my quick start guide I highly
highly recommend that because it'll save
you just a ton of time there are like so
many RL papers and the vast majority of
them are just going to waste your time
uh I actually think the majority of them
are wrong we'll be showing you uh that
will be coming soon though this one
where's
this let me find my article for
you here 20 minute read for after
stream python background for simple
applications yeah so any side the hard
thing with RL is there's like a much
deeper engineering side to the stack uh
our environments are in C they're an
incredibly simple C it's very easy to
pick up but you do need to know stuff
like what a memory allocation and what a
pointer
is was doing something similar using T
show project you showed is interesting
thanks yeah no worry so Tano is pretty
good I think it's just it's a very
complex Library uh and it it doesn't
even have all the perf optimizations
that puffer does so really puffer is
it's fast it's simple right it doesn't
have all the algorithms it's not like
built out this like massive massive
thing but it is very fast it's very
simple
covers most things you'd want to
do t-x compiled ufb
is okay
so we have to search both of these
okay so R I9 gets 3200 and 16k
[Music]
3200 multicore is kind of low
but yeah multicore is very low on this
actually that's
decent interesting single cor score
matches
though uh do you have traffic and in
poer Li saw teacher working on traffic
Sim conclusions that's the reason so
I don't know if anybody has a good
traffic Sim at the
one there's also some of the NYU guys if
you like at Eugene or dapne one of those
people on Twitter uh they might have
traffic Sim stuff uh they the one that's
in petting zoo is really
okay this thing don't use this thing
this thing is like God awful slow uh
unfortunately so maybe people have
better ones but like this one when I
tried it was like horribly horribly
slow um we could make this fast we
we would probably just need somebody to
Port this to c as all so like it this is
like a good project for not a beginner
beginner but this is like a good like
midsize project for someone with a
little bit of C experience and a little
bit of Spare Time medium amount of spare
time not as complicated as GPU
Drive which it doesn't have to be be for
just simulating traffic not
driving okay so this
is started something similar but only
for
highways
awesome if you want to do that stuff uh
that would be great Nathan though I hope
you'll do a a base line for the tactics
and I mean that thing could be the
tactics Ms you made could really really
be
cool I want to see uh I want to see
something figure out how to fight the
tofu
AI okay so geek bench result here
is
for
990x
is pretty spread
awful but there are people submitting
these at
though the thing is the single core look
the multi core could be low is allowed
to be low cuz I'm doing other stuff but
there should be a core free for it to do
single
core so this gets 1400 multicore as well
which is yeah
awful it's surprising to me how
variable the results are on this
one like the Intel results are pretty
darn consistent
school project to do that would be a
mini thesis still have to pick the
subject still have to pick the subject
yeah great I mean it's really just a
matter of like setting aside a weekend
and starting to write some code we have
lots of lots of samples to help you get
started I'm streaming constantly to help
people
out making traffic Sim on puffer yeah I
don't know how far Nathan got on that uh
hard too hard it's not too hard on the
RL side it just depends on uh whether
you can competently write simple C code
like you should look at some of the code
here this is what you should look
at ah this is our business
page old business
this is our sample
project if you look at the like the code
in here this is like as simple as it
gets you can look at some of the other
ends in here like
breakout snake and so on but that's
about as simple as it gets and this is I
promise you the simplest C environment
code out there that you will find we
have it really really try to keep it
simple
I'm trying to think what to do about
this Benchmark
okay it's just like a big battery of a
bunch of
tests but still they should
is thanks man going to read don't want
to distract you back to Discord yeah no
worries thanks for dropping by
these scores are like crazy
[Music]
variable I want not not going to be able
to bench my
weird I didn't do it backwards right
this is the same
right so on everything but Cy bench it
does
way
worse which is weird because the single
core suspens is higher
oh you know what I'm going to do I know
what I'm going to
do I'm going to download the windows
version just to see if there's WSL
overhead that's
smart we're going to get the windows
version just to see if it matches the
WSL
report that'll eliminate that as the V
that one variable
CPU it's so funny how the Linux version
is just a single CLI and this has like
this layo UI
funny does anybody know uh better
benchmarks or anything like I just want
to really get a sense of for sure
whether this particular system the CPU
is underperforming what it should be or
not because according to pass Mark uh I
should be getting comparable single core
perf and 10% higher multicore perf uh
versus my I9 and I'm getting like way
lower
perf funny how somehow their CPU
Benchmark also takes longer
winders it's also not just the stream
for reference like I tried uh some basic
CPU benchmarks before off stream when uh
you know when I didn't have anything
else running on a fresh boot uh and
regardless it shouldn't matter because
you should have idle cores anyways that
that are at zero and it should just like
the operating system should just grab a
free core and run the heavy workload on
the free core unless it's really
stupid so we're going to see if this
matches
um this is our original
machine multicore score is really not
that good
16x and then here is
the AMD
perf actually let's compare clang
3400 versus 3,000
on AMD that's
weird so we'll wait for the CPU bench to
finish hopefully that tells us
something anybody on the Discord need
anything in the meantime
well we're good I do have some good
experiments running in the background as
well not on this machine obviously but
on you know other machines I'm going to
be happy to share
later is beat bench good I don't know if
their thing is
okay this is nice not reason not well
versed with Hardware
what would you think is this case how
your RAM configs would offence well the
thing is that the AMD one has
ddr5 and the
uh the Intel machine has ddr4 but the
Intel machine is over is outperforming
which is weird like I have a $4,000 box
that's outperforming this box which is a
$5,500 box at the moment which is nuts
here why is there no
99 there's no 9950 on here
Ram yeah it's just very it would be very
weird as all because
like yes that's technically possible but
it would be surprising if whatever the
hell configur I have on my
ddr4 box is better than the stock
ddr5 I'd have to go check bios and stuff
for that as well
are here are our
results okay so it actually did
improve it improved going
from not what WSL
does WSL actually have substantial
overhead I thought it was pretty much
good CPU Z has a simple bench I'll try
that next
uh YouTube Elite the link but I'll look
it
time this is literally no build time
what am I looking
none of these have results is this
article like AI written or
something or am I just
blinded there are no actual
might be time to get off
Windows uh I really can't tell if I'm
like just blind here because I don't see
any
results is this like one of those things
where the
Articles oh next page
de okay
yeah so there's this is what I expected
there's very very marginal difference
and there like a couple Niche things
where W
okay so it shouldn't be
this let me run geek bench again on my
local because that was weird that it's
that different
okay so here
is bad single core good single core
318 32 okay so this is
now comparable right we get like the
sameish single core
per let's see how what the variability
is
and then what happened to multicore so
it went up to
16k okay so this is actually now it
reports about the
same um off of WSL let's let's confirm
difference somebody's got to have done
more of this
so it's just cross file system
stuff is bad that's the only
yeah these are very small numbers when
people are benchmarking
consistently let's see
um so here is the second
test which is
consistent okay that's very odd
so when I run
this we get dramatically different
results let's figure out
why is it just across the
board
[Music]
oh
wait hold
on it's doing file system
crap n there too many things here that
are
be I'm trying to think if I have to move
everything to Linux in order to get um
reasonable results
though
right like do I have to stick a bunch of
on this just to get
I mean even with better
Ram still didn't get any
[Music]
better how does m match their
uh let me see
3100 that's in range of what we'
expect the results for this are very
very much all over the place
though
way I'm trying to think what I can do
actionable out of this
me that these are probably very
comparable
chips but there is a well hold
on maybe there's something here so
multie this is supposed to be almost as
good
right multicore this is supposed to be
almost as
good there are a couple things I can
still do
with yeah so this is 16 workers 48 bat
so 16 *
3 and then this again time four so we're
going to
why is back size set to
48 oh yeah it's fine
4816 this gets
30k it's possible didn't find best
settings though
it's possible that we just didn't find
the best settings there is a fundamental
architecture
difference so breakout
AMD should be right here
now right here
do we're going to change this to 32 and
see what
happens the thing I'm worried about here
is that there are 24 cores versus 16
cores and that can cause different
optimal Lo
tests CPU faulty no I don't think so
because
uh on Windows it mostly
matches it mostly matches on Windows
what we'd
expect uh on the synthetic
48 um none of the new M's really
matter
uh how's that possible there's that big
of a
difference I thought it went higher than
this as well I thought I got 150
oh because it reduces to
Max that's fine
here 135 yeah that's what we would
expect roughly
bizarre it's like sometimes just
randomly massively slower
Lottery I'd be very surprised if it's
something like that going on I think
it's all four Stick config as
well this should have better ramp the
AMD Buck should have better RAM on it
yeah this got mandly faster I'm not
comfortable including this one because I
don't know proon might have some screw
stuff going on with it it's like
compiled I think it's like pre-compiled
or something
or net hack actually yeah let's do net
hack net hack will be
better nck could be a spot where RAM
does make a
difference really big observations
a lot of test playing with AMD
preferences out of the box settings are
bad these aren't even overclocked is the
thing thing
this this is the last one we're going to
run
80 and there the Intel box getting 100K
48 24 48
actually I'm going to get the proon
result
yeah cuz here's the this is the exact
Pro gen
sensitive the word like the technical
term for a Fini system is just bad
though is the
yeah well now these are freaking server
processors man you're linking
me you're linking me epyc
okay I9 13900 K here is at
5900 and then 14900 K so we have 60,000
is our base Blen right so 60,000 Ben
epyc it's like double
per but even then
like you'd have to be pretty
strongly CPU Bound for this stuff
to factor
in where's Intel's next
gen and we just have this
okay they added a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
great Ultra
[Music]
I9 yeah this is what we're looking
comparison okay is Intel just a dead
company at this point
how's this thing worse perpose is
scoring higher on the bench
what a terrible year for Consumer
Hardware holy
gems uh I mean yeah I
guess the way that typically we're going
to deal with these though is we buy the
desktops we hold them for like two two
and a halfish years use them for RL and
then we'll flip them to sell for uh
we'll sell them as like mid-end
commodity desktops by that time probably
for about
here oops I don't even have a
4K that actually looks better
um cine banch
see so they have
multicore up top
here so what are people mad
top power consumption
fun is
lower we don't care about file
[Music]
manager what is Corona
10 is this software rendering
there's so much stuff that can affect
game per though it's weird
these are like game per
tests I
obviously not what we're getting we
should just ignore this chip for the
purpose of Ben marks this is an8 qu
chip so
duh you're going to get a 16 C chip for
so
yeah the per agressions are kind of
weird though if it
has uh if it has
better single core per right
threads 8 p
course oh did
what they changed this to lower thread
count
apparently there are stability issues
with the ult with these new ones as
Hardware I here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to go make a quick call to
main gear I'm going to figure out what's
going on over there with their
stuff
um and I'm going to finish this document
then we'll have a current state of
Hardware in
RL uh I think it's generally just kind
of [ __ ] all around
because the AMD chips are like
okay I guess they're not it seems slower
than um it it seems like slower in real
applications as far as I can tell unless
I mean the only thing I can think is
that maybe I really have to try this
on
think because there is a pretty decent
difference
yeah that's like a decent chunk
here the multicore is very similar
though like the multicore shouldn't be
this different and like we're getting
just
massive birf differences
here and I also I don't like that it's
just randomly it's also just randomly
sometimes half
speed for several tasks
this could be WSL though to be fair this
could totally be
WSL uh I'm going to make a quick call to
main gear I was hoping to get this done
this morning but I think I might have to
just install uh I might have to just
stick Linux on this
box tinkering with parts no you're
allowed to swap
stuff you're uh it depends it depends
but you're you are allowed to swap stuff
um
sure I'm not sure if it's worth me
trying to stick Linux on this box
completely I mean this like this
Benchmark difference is
I mean it's just nuts because like you
got to it's like pick your poison
pay only a little bit more box to be
fair
but this is potentially worse
perf they cut thread count as well which
is
weird
versus 950x
I probably need to just stick this on
auntu don't
I I just need to get like an auntu
USB dual boot dual boot this to
auntu go see how that works most likely
it's just obnoxious because that's going
to take me a decent chunk of the
afternoon later
today but I think that's probably what
I'm going to have to do
um I mean but like the best case for
that is I think that the best
case is that takes us to probably same
single
and like 10% faster
all and then they only do DDR five now
which
oh well rip
yeah and the kits got more expensive
because now it's all ddr5 as
well that just sucks when stuff just
gets like that okay like literally the
best boxes I got were the ones that had
the uh they don't even have it anymore
the 13900 K though that one technically
could have been unstable as
well well I'm I got to stop delaying
here I mean there's like it's going to
be a tough situation all around for
appying hard at the moment um companies
got to get their [ __ ]
together AMD perf might be okay and it
might just be I can cut costs on
RAM and um motherboard and
stuff so yeah we'll
see okay uh I'm going to call it for now
I'm going to be back
in probably I'll be back by 300 p.m. so
3 three and a half hours I'm going to
take care of some stuff and uh that's
what we'll be doing for now so thanks
folks and uh if you haven't already join
the Discord discord.gg puffer uh
hopefully I won't just be doing Hardware
stuff all day hopefully there will be
some
Dev
but uh you can go ahead and start the
repo helps me out a ton and there will
be more stuff here if not later today
than the latest tomorrow thanks folks